AR JORUROU  TNL STAENTIRE NATIO
ECTION RATE ACTUALLY
GOING WN OREDASAVE
NOWER
WEERSTATES,HERE
HOLDINGSTEAURGE IEMENTS R STE TS
WEE A G.
LINESFARTSIDE A CLINICRE
MEOR THEIR
SECOND OR T HAV
TURN
THIS IS IN THE TEXAS,
MOSTATE
CO NOT ONLY ISHE
CASE SI
NUMBER OF BNGVERY DAY.WEALK TO .
THIS ME ARE MINFETEXAS,T' IN LO
CE RE TO
MASKGOVERN O KANSAS A
STATEWIDEKRINAIMPOSE AND
GYMS AIG PARKS. THE ION RATE PLO
REOPEN ANDORK IS CO TSAME.LL OF.
WESCTOUROVERYONE
WEUN>> SOES HE VETHI WHORELYETSS
CO SAID
.  OFFICIAL I
TATE AEAR AMASK, WEVERYON AD AR
WH Y'TAICING, MASK IDWILL, WE KA
S JUST
SA HOWT
EDLYSASKCE HALTINGLYUR T
S.HE SHOULD, LIKE OGRESS PEOPLE
FTER ALLNOWN BEEOINGON, T.
WRI M  WEEKS AND BACKING
PRESIDENT WHO DSNR
ES ICA BUNKER
AND EVERYONE AUN S
MNGO  SUGST WEAMASK.
WHY D YICE
THE ONLY REASON T.HE SCAPREST.T
RO FOR HE'S CALLING THELE AGAIN?
OH, YEAH,S
INCHOU CRC DH0-PERSHO WHOM
APPEAR AANGES  WEARING
LU SNTOOSGING AROUND THEM.
THIS IS WHERE WE
AN
EV AK SOMEFGR
ALLEGE LEADINGHEGAINST VIRUS.
THOSE SAME LISFRIDAY'S FIRST I
>>T T, YE TO HIN S DO THAT BUTT
NOTICE HE'STENSE.THONS
D THE
IDENTREALOVNM
WHOL GOVERNORSED IV T  HBIG N A
THEBRIE WHEN ORLL BE  FIRUSAR A
PLAINOEE CORTS OEIMPLYNOEXIST.
Y
COUNTRI T PTH THE GREEE TREUP,E
ITALY.
DOW AIN DTHO. T
ECIT P D
CONA
AND WE DIDN'T STICKIT.REA N H TO
NATIONAL LEVEL AND TND SERIOUSLD
E'VE
EMONE IREDUCES A THIRD.HINGSS UL
PP HANDLE
INESHAT WE'VE EN
THE UIDELI AUIRED AND PRE
J CD
GUIN EMBER.AYAGNGTHOSE AREN'T R
CALLS ANT'
ISENOSINT  SOCAL
OFG ADOING.
HOW MANYES YOU HEAR
PRESIDENT ANDHE
UR P TO M   HIS SECRE OALTH AND
TAVHE
MONTHS AGO WHENRESIDE
SA
>>ITE OF
ISBEOWLOZE,YE  ACAY WINDOW I G.
NG
CNN M EANF THENATION
DIILOR CGE BAYLOR EEDICIN
SHE THINKS PEOPLE EG AND SUMME
WOD AND EVEGOUSIDENT SAID IT'SIE
WHERE THE EUNION A WRERE AND AN
TH ANDY IND W'T MEAN,T
LEADERSHIP.
OAN, BECAUSE YOU THUMANS ISAME N
OF HOW IT BEHAVEINS
AROUND THE WORLD AND T LDORS,
R
MILLION PEOPLE AROUND
THE WAV
INEFFECTED AND 00AVE DI
A QUARTER OF THOSE NUMBERS
HERE IN THE UTED TH OBVIOUSLY,
ANDERSON, AAD AS TERS A
SEEHAPENINGNE OFTE IELSAY INISTN
G.IGGER CONC YOUMENTIONED ITAL
TA HIGH IN ITATH ?AIN
ON T HSTEM, PEOPLE WHO  I G CARE
CALLEDTUATHS,BSOLUT AND PREVENT.
THAT THE A NC
TE IS HERE IN HON.
HOUHOHEUSP LIKE WHEREOT TO
CARE.
TH COU B MYOV SHORTNESS OF
BREATH, THEY NEED THOSPITAL ANDD